I'm sure some people are new to my show
so allow me to introduce myself my name
is John's Jeremy John's Skyfall
so Skyfall is the newest addition in the
double-oh-seven franchise on the third
Bond movie with Daniel Craig as James
Bond second if you don't count Quantum
of Solace like most normal human beings
on the face of the planet and in Skyfall
we get a very different James Bond type
of story first of all James Bond as you
can tell when you just look at the guy
you're like you look up you look like
you're aging so in this movie they
totally play off of that James Bond has
fallen from grace he comes back because
there's this terrorist that's just going
after mi6 and James Bond is one rusty
bastard that could make for a really
boring James Bond movie but it's not I
mean from the intro the movie you have
this sweet action scene then you have
the James Bond intro and you're like
this song is awesome the visuals are
badass and after that you get the James
Bond movie that in my opinion it's the
one we deserve and the one we need
because Casino Royale is still my
favorite Bond movie I loved it but
old-school Bond fans were like it kind
of alienates us because it's such a new
take on James Bond has none of the
old-school James Bond isms in it it was
a reboot of the Bond franchise in every
way possible Skyfall was what Casino
Royale was in terms of a darker more
realistic James Bond but I had enough
old-school fun throwbacks and references
to old-school James Bond movies so those
James Bond fans can be like oh yeah the
movies including us and it also so fans
of Casino Royale should love Skyfall
old-school Bond fans should love Skyfall
basically Skyfall is just all-around
likable why it worked it's very simple
first of all we'll touch on the dialogue
and the characters both are great and
both work well together
Daniel Craig is James Bond he's my
favorite James Bond because he's smooth
and he's a ladies man but in that
tough-guy kind of way he looks like he
can charm a chick but yet still kick-ass
he's not like Hank Moody with a gun
where you're like oh yeah you can get
chicks and well the script says you will
win and that's why you'll win you feel
like Daniel Craig just earns it all Judi
Dench's em I love Judi Dench as M more
and more every time I see her and in
Skyfall this is no exception Judi Dench
is great as em and what I like is
characters like Judi Dench's m and the
new Q who is also good there are
relevant pieces in this movie they're
not just there for the sake of like oh
yeah Judi Dench shows em and she's in
this movie because
em Oh a new young face is Q he's in the
movie because people wanted to see Q
back they're actually relevant as part
of the plot in the movie and they do
stuff that matters they're not just
character filler I love that and the
dialogue between James Bond and these
characters is fantastic it shows that he
has a relationship with these people
Judi Dench and James Bond they bicker
back and forth but you can tell there's
like you know this mother-son type of
relationship there James Bond and Q they
bicker back and forth at first he's like
look how young you are so they have
fantastic dialogue back and forth and
that you can tell that moment where
they're like yeah I respect you now
because you held your own verbally
against me and one of the chicks in this
movie the dialogue between her and James
Bond was completely interesting also
she's a spy so she's sexy and efficient
they had their sexual tension so they
have their banter back and forth which
makes her completely relevant like of
the Bond girls that I remember she is by
far the most interesting and I love that
I mean people who want their bond check
for the sake of a hot bond chick being a
bond chick well yeah she's in this movie
too and she is really hot however if you
want a hot relevant chick it's this
chick that works with James Bond because
it's all about the pursuit it's like
they finally learned it like you know
what the hunt is sweeter than the gyal
so we'll have sexual tension and banter
between James Bond and this chick and
that will be a hundred times more
interesting than James Bond just nail in
some other chair and let's just touch on
it here Javier Bardem is the bad guy the
dude is completely villainously
evil and awesome he is pissed off he is
on a vendetta and you just you're like
this guy when he talks is just out of
his mind the first shot with him is just
one still shot where he is just
monologuing walking towards the camera
there's no stitching it together it's
just one shot of him walking towards the
camera talking great intro the only
thing that was missing from this intro
is the magic trick in which he might
just shove a pencil through a guy's face
what has been done and on that shoehorn
segue I would just go into it like this
Skyfall is like The Dark Knight of the
Bond movies it's thicker than you think
it'll be it has layers to that you
didn't expect would be there it's a very
involved movie to a surprising degree
calling Skyfall a Bond movie is like
calling the Dark Knight a Batman movie
just doesn't quite do it justice and the
movies shot well too usually I'm not one
of those people like moon those shots
are fantastic That's not me but when I
notice them I noticed them so if you are
one of those people that watches movies
you're like and I
that camera angle just did not suffice
look at Skyfall Oh notice that it is
shot very very well you can tell the
director put all the thought in the
world to every shot in this movie if I
have any gripes about the movie they're
not really gripes just like things that
I feel need to be addressed first of all
like I said in Skyfall being like The
Dark Knight of the Bond movies it's very
involved and in that you can't just
casually watch it you have to be in the
mindset to want to watch a
two-and-a-half-hour movie that's really
thick with character really thick with
plot can't just be like oh I casually
want to watch a Bond movie put in
Skyfall again that's not a gripe it's
actually a big compliment to the movie
but I do feel that needs to be addressed
it's not for casual watching and second
of all I don't think this was done on
purpose it's just something that I
noticed it took me out of the movie for
a second I couldn't help but see the
similarities between the end of Skyfall
and the end of hard-target yeah I said
that hard-target again I'm not going to
hold it against this movie because I
don't think the people that penned this
script arguably one of the best Bond
scripts ever we're like okay this is
solid great dialogue great characters
now for the end we're gonna rip off hard
target I think it's just a coincidence
it's a coincidence that I noticed so it
took me out of the movie a bit I'm
saying if you've seen hard target and
you saw Skyfall you gotta admit you
thought of it too so great dialogue
great characters a great Bond a great
Bond villain a deeper premise and I
thought I was going to be in for a movie
that shot well a movie with great action
sequences what is missing from this
movie except an official writing that I
can give it it always leaves kind of a
bad taste in my mouth to give two of
these in two weeks but I just got to do
it because in terms of Bond movie I feel
that Skyfall deserves to be awesome
tacular
or so after Daniel Craig who do you
think should be the next James Bond
whoever you think it should be comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more